bei uns ist jetzt der Chef des
Bundeswehrverbandes Oberst André Wüstner
hier bei uns im Studio schön dass Sie
bei uns sind hallo jetzt sollen man hat
sich dazu entschlossen Waffen an die
Ukraine geliefert werden kann das in
dieser Situation überhaupt möglich sein
wie läuft so etwas ab so eine
Waffenlieferung wie stellen wir sicher
dass diese Waffen dort überhaupt
ankommen das ist eine schwierige
Operation man muss teilweise fliegen es
geht um Landtransport und natürlich darf
man diese Routen vorher nicht offenlegen
aber es ist eine Herausforderung der
aktuellen Lage und man weiß ja auch all
das was jetzt noch folgt das wird
schlimmer werden ich bin bei Ihnen auch
bei Thema Zurückhaltung was die
Friedensverhandlungen anbelangt ich
glaube eher Putin versucht sich gerade
Zeit zu verschaffen er führt neue Kräfte
ran der Angriff ist ja zum Stocken
gelangen und es wird die nächsten Tage
bitterer werden was wir dort erleben und
deswegen kann ich nachvollziehen dass
auch Menschen sich jetzt Gedanken machen
Kiew und andere Städte zu verlassen
hoffe aber dass die Ukraine weiterhin
tapfer bisher kämpfen denn damit hat
Putin nicht gerechnet er gleichermaßen
nicht damit gerechnet dass die NATO das
Europa das die westliche Gemeinschaft so
geschlossen steht und ich bin gespannt
wie er weiter agiert nur es ist ja
wichtig dass diese Waffen ganz schnell
ankommen und wir sehen dass dort quasi
ein Countdown abläuft so sehen es
zumindest die Menschen in Kiew ja
offenbar die Rennen auf dem Bahnsteig
die machen sich nicht nur Gedanken wie
sie rauskommen sondern die nehmen ihre
Beine in die Hand die flüchten jetzt die
wollen noch in den Zug reindrängen in
die möglicherweise letzten Züge das
heißt die Waffen müssen schnell da sein
geben Sie uns mit ihrer Expertise einmal
eine Einschätzung wie schnell kann das
gehen das ist ja keine geringe Menge das
sind 1000 Panzer Fäuste das sind
Abwehrraketen das schleppt man mal nicht
soeben schnell über die Grenze rüber ich
gehe davon aus dass das heute wenn nicht
schon gestern begonnen hat und wenn es
dann darum geht die direkt an die Front
zu bringen dann ist es natürlich eine
Frage der einzellogistik wie man das
macht das werden teilweise keine
Militärkonvois sein sondern
behelfsfahrzeuge Sprinter was auch immer
um sozusagen auch verdeckt versteckt wie
auch immer getarnt diese Waffen nach
vorne zu bringen aber ich gebe Ihnen
Recht also abwarten ist nicht mal mehr
die zweitbeste Option die diese
Bewaffnung muss jetzt nach vorne und sie
wird ja auch genutzt wie man gerade erst
wieder gesehen haben
sagen Sie ihr seid zu gestern Putin der
ganzen westlichen Welt gedroht mit
seinen Atomwaffen da stellen sich bei
mir ganz pragmatische fragen was hat
dieser Mann genau wie weit kann das
reichen wie sehr ist Deutschland davon
bedroht also auf der einen Seite sage
ich es ist nichts Neues denn in der
Phase Annexion der Krim hatte ähnlich
agiert nichtsdestotrotz Putin agiert
aktuell so irrational wie nie zuvor das
heißt wir wissen nicht handelt eher nach
einem Doktrin Handbuch und wir können
sozusagen beurteilen was der nächste
Schnitt Schritt ist oder passiert nicht
Dinge mit denen wir so eigentlich nicht
rechnen wollen wir wissen dass Atom
U-Boote ausgelaufen sind oder gerade
Auslaufen im Nordmeer mit Mittelstrecken
und
intercontinentalraketen wir wissen er
ist auch in der Lage kleine Sprengsätze
im Bereich von Städten oder auch anderen
Regionen dieser Welt zu zünden deswegen
ist wichtig dass der Nachrichtendienst
in seinem Verbund international jetzt
dran bleibt weil noch mal das ist nicht
ungefährlich auch wenn ich keinem nichts
machen will den Angst und Wut sind ja
nie gute Ratgeber aber muss diese
Situation genau beobachten dieser
Raketen nach den Informationen die wir
haben sind die auf Deutschland auch
gerichtet auf Berlin beispielsweise nein
dafür da reingehend habe ich keine
Kenntnisse aber der Punkt ist der wir
wissen ja nicht nur Stichwort Atom
U-Boote Putin hat ja an mehreren Ecken
dieser Welt bisschen nach Syrien solche
ja Waffen geliefert verteilt disloziert
wir wissen Kaliningrad ist ein Standort
wo er jederzeit entsprechender Raketen
zünden kann mit einem entsprechenden
Radius aber noch ist es so dass wir
nicht in dieser Eskalationsspirale sind
mich wundert das so ein bisschen denn es
ist ja auch ein Tick feige also
konventionell kommt er nicht weiter aber
jetzt meinte er müsste schon abschrecken
über eine atomare Variante oder diese
mit ins Spiel bringen das ist zwar
einerseits ein politisches Zeichen aber
es erhöht auch die Brisanz dieses
Konflikts und dennoch fragt man sich
natürlich wo genau sind eigentlich
unsere NATO Atomraketen wo sind die über
positioniert man spielt das natürlich
durch im Kopf und denkt sich Putin
konnte es mit so einer Drohung wie wäre
denn unsere Reaktion wie würde das
Ablaufen ja grundsätzlich ist es dann
Eskalationsspirale auf beiden Seiten da
kann und will ich jetzt gar nicht zu
viel dazu sagen aber der Punkt ist der
da gibt es Pläne und es gibt auch wo die
stationiert sind ist das Hoch geheim
weiß man das wo sind die nato-atomwaffen
in unserer Nähe also ich weiß einiges
aber das kann ich hier nicht sagen aha
gut da können wir glaube ich auch nicht
weiter nachfragen aber gut dass sie es
wissen und das ist sie gibt da kann man
sich das im Zweifel letzte Frage Herr
Oberst gestern gab es eine wichtige
Bundestagssitzung es gab nur 180 Grad
Wände in der deutschen Politik es gab
einerseits darüber haben wir gesprochen
die Zusicherung jetzt eben doch deutsche
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine und
gleichzeitig 100 Milliarden Euro für Sie
für die Bundeswehr in den nächsten
Jahren nachdem all dem was sie in den
vergangenen Jahren Unterfinanzierung und
ewig lange Rüstungsprojekte erlebt haben
bei der Bundeswehr gehen sie überhaupt
davon aus dass sie noch was davon von
den 100 Milliarden Euro gehe ich davon
aus gestern definitiv das war irgendwie
ein historischer Tag in jeglicher
Hinsicht mit Blick auf das was passiert
ist im Parlament Standing Ovations auch
in Richtung Botschaft Botschafter aus
der Ukraine aber überhaupt die
Gesamthaltung die sag mal neu
Ausrichtung der außenpolitischen Achse
Deutschlands da ist ja etwas passiert
ich weiß gar nicht wie man das
beschreiben soll aber auch in historisch
mit Blick auf die Bundeswehr weil diese
unsere Politik dieses Parlament endlich
erkannt hat Sicherheit geht nicht für
null Frieden muss verteidigt werden und
das heißt eben auch dass nicht nicht nur
sagen kann innere und äußere Sicherheit
sind kein staatlichen Handel so ich muss
unterfüttern und jetzt ist eine Aufgabe
der Verteidigungsministerin daraus etwas
zu machen denn viel Geld muss nicht
unbedingt richtig eingesetzt werden und
das ist jetzt so das Gebot der Stunde
jetzt zu unterfüttern bei Munition bei
Schutzwesten bei Bewaffnung bei
Fahrzeugen etc um nicht nur mit Blick
auf diesen aktuellen Konflikt in der
Ukraine uns fit zu machen sondern
insbesondere für die Situation wenn wir
direkt einen neuen US-Präsident haben
der sagt ihr Europäer kümmert euch jetzt
mal selbst dann endlich europäisch fit
zu sein und eine gute
Sicherheitsarchitektur
danke danke ebenso